at just about every organization it's
someone's job to prepare slide decks
that contain lots of informative data
points
now this process often involves writing
queries and then manually adding the
results into each slide but who wants to
spend all that time copying and pasting
well we're about to make your life a
whole lot easier
in this video we'll walk through how you
can use google apps scripts to automate
data-driven slide development
[Music]
let's imagine you're a data analyst on
the e-commerce team for a huge retailer
each week you're tasked with preparing
google slides for the director to
present to the broader team
the problem this is a super time
consuming task
you're going to need to query the
e-commerce data to come up with the
total sales new customers number of
orders and repeat purchase rate
but wait that's not it
there are more than 20 different
departments and each one needs their own
slide
my thumb and index fingers are hurting
just thinking about all those control c
and control v's
lucky for you your company already has
their ecommerce data living inside of
bigquery
and one of the many great things about
bigquery is the flexibility it offers in
terms of interacting with your data
bigquery has a variety of apis client
libraries and out of the box
integrations with different google
services
all of which make it easy to access your
data where and when you need it
in this tutorial we'll be using
bigquery's api as a service that's
natively available in google apps script
all right ready let's jump in
so the first step in automating the
development of these slides is to define
our metrics using sql
let's say we'll calculate total sales
for each slide by filtering our orders
to a specific department
on a given week
then summing up the total sales of all
the items ordered
now to ensure we're consistently
calculating our metrics we can go ahead
and create a user-defined function
inside of bigquery
with our function defined we can run it
anytime we need to calculate total sales
simply by feeding in a department name
and week timed sam
but what about actually pushing the
results of this function into a slide
one option for programmatically
developing slides is to create a
template slide that we'll use for
formatting
here i've created a pretty simple
template
where variables that will be
programmatically pushed into our slide
are surrounded by distinguishable
characters
like these double curly brackets
in my template i can control things like
where on the slide these variables
should be printed
and the color of the text
great so we have our template all ready
to go
now to actually run the calculations and
populate this template we'll turn to
google apps script
google apps script is a scripting
environment for lightweight javascript
development within the google workspace
platform
inside the apps script ide we're able to
add google services to our program
directly through the ui
this will make interacting with the apis
much easier since there is less setup
than using their http interfaces
once we've added the services we'll be
using bigquery drive and slides we're
ready to start coding
first we'll need to make a copy of the
template slide deck to use as our weekly
presentation
next we'll loop through each department
create a new slide and then call this
function
zooming in a bit you can see that this
function goes into our new slide and
iterates through each metric
for each metric we'll use this helper
function to call the bigquery api and
run the euds that we created earlier
finally we'll replace the string
containing the curly brackets and our
metric name with the result from
bigquery
when the loop completes we'll have one
slide for each department with all our
templated metrics filled in
appropriately
and the finishing touch
since you need this available for the
director at the beginning of each week
let's go ahead and add a trigger to run
the script every monday morning
with integrations across google services
you can deliver your data wherever and
whenever the business needs it
leveraging google apps scripts to
automate data fueled document
development
opens up huge opportunities to save
analysts time when it comes to quarterly
business reviews or financial reporting
ready to get started check out the link
below to see some code samples
[Music]
you